but let's read this first story from cnn
trump unleashes new threat to american
democracy
i think this should actually be titled
something like cnn has trump derangement
syndrome
and they are unhinged trump trump
basically just said the things he always
says there i got to be honest the
headline should actually be
we're lying to scare people the
president said the same thing he said
last month
that's that i mean look he gave a speech
i guess you know cassandra you liked it
i loved it i thought it was fun
but it wasn't like he was just like
bringing back a lot of the same talking
points
it sounded like usual campaign trump
right
and i personally love that but it wasn't
anything outrageous it wasn't different
it wasn't anything he hasn't said before
let me let me read some of this donald
trump has
no remorse about the deadly violence he
incited with his lies
about a stolen election in his uprising
against the u.s congress like wow
definitively donald trump did this and
it's okay
this much was clear when the
ex-president put the republican party on
notice sunday that he intends to use his
hold on its grassroots to try and
suppress the vote heading into the
presidential election
in 2024 what does that mean in which he
hinted he might run
how is he suppressing the vote if he
doesn't run no one's going to vote for
the republicans i mean
there will be some people voting
republican but this is just
absolutely hilarious they're going to
mention that he rags in the supreme
court
and they say you know leave last seen
leaving washington in disgrace
the ex-president self regarding wander
through old political fights
emphasized his obsession with revenge
at a time when the attention on the
majority of the nation not in his campus
concentrating on more immediate concerns
the distribute distribution of a third
coveted vaccine yeah yeah okay we get it
it's just the most bombastic language
they're saying that most people are
focusing on the vaccine
the white house had a press conference
at the exact same time as trump's speech
about a new vaccine and literally nobody
watched it
why would you nobody watched it
everybody was watching trump's speech
like they're
they're so like detached from reality
even people who hate trump are addicted
to them yeah
and so everyone all eyes were on that
someone pointed out there was like a
meme going around of of like the white
house press briefing or whatever on
covet or something i don't even know
what it was because i didn't know what
was happening and it didn't even break a
million views
and then trump's speech had like three
hundred thousand yeah no like 3.5
million views
yeah like like an hour trump had a
million people watching at
one time it was like 900 000 people were
watching him give a speech some
ridiculous number
yeah dude so so check this out let me
let me pull up the uh
the unhinge let's just i'm just going to
read the headline
vox.com writes the republican revolt
against
democracy explained in 13 charts
the trump years revealed a dark truth
the republican party is no longer
committed to democracy these charts tell
the story
you know when we get media like cnn
saying this crazy stuff there's no
effort
at all to try and like calm people down
calm down
he's just speaking at a republican
convention he's just smack talking it's
it's political rhetoric just chill out
no they're like this is the end
he is unleashing a new threat and
republicans are of abandoned democracy
like do they want fighting and violence
yes
it's good for raiders that's great oh
yeah their clicks have to be way down
right now there's like no bogeyman
cnn's ratings went down 40 to the week
after joe biden came into office wow
jeez
yeah so they're bleeding money i i guess
jim acosta got replaced
jeff zucker's planning on leaving like
cnn's so yeah they're definitely like
we do all i keep thinking is this is the
kind of stuff that i would like to see
written about a president that
authorized the bombing of syria
and blaming an iraqi militia that may or
may not have
not was an iraqi iranian a militia yeah
like like the new york times is like
iranian-backed militias and then in the
article we don't know if that's true
you want to talk about a threat to
democracy like that that should be what
the focus of this vitriol is but instead
it's it's
trump's you know it's bombing with
diversity though yeah
well then you can go to sleep it's like
all these democrats tweeting like isn't
it great having military action under
biden we can all rest easy
why what's the difference a bombing's a
bombing this is what turned me off of
the left originally
um i was protesting more under bush
i was a leftist until six years ago
i protested like crazy um during bush
and then under obama everybody
disappeared except for like
a few code pink people and stuff
everybody was like
went back to sleep didn't care and i was
watching and he was droning everyone and
i was like hey guys
are we still anti-war what's going on
you're not a racist are you
you would criticize obama
i i don't want to bomb little brown kids
in foreign nations
i'm a monster no see that's colorism
because obama is actually
more brown it's not racist when he bombs
them because they have color like they
have they have white privilege
it makes sense colorism is a thing they
started talking what is it
like the lighter your skin apparently
you get like certain privileges i guess
so it's like i guess the idea was that
when they had when they started talking
about white privilege
the problem was that asians typically
have like higher incomes in education so
they're like well
i mean it's you well if you're closer to
white then you have privilege too so
that that that explains it
it doesn't but for sure well let me pull
up these charts because this is crazy
stuff look at it so vox.com
first today's republicans really hate
democrats
and democracy one trump supporters have
embraced
anti-democratic ideas this is not true
it's just false framing
but let me show you what they say maga
supporters who
support trump's election fraud claims
nearly 100
of trump supporters support his claims
on fraud distrust the election results
same percentage nearly 100 believe
voting shouldn't be easier
about 90 percent uh distrust 2020
congressional election results
about 80 percent want a third term for
trump only about 70 percent want a third
term for trump
but i'll tell you not trusting the
election system does not mean you
oppose democracy or democratic ideas it
means you think
one thing was wrong well when i was on
the left
we didn't trust the election results
either i mean they rigged it against
bernie
i still believe that um i never believed
election results i remember
even under like bush i was like there's
no way this guy got a second term i
don't trust this like i've never
i've always thought elections were
rigged and i always think of the mark
twain quote where he's like if
you know voting actually mattered they
wouldn't let you do it it would be
illegal yeah
and so i i mean i've always thought that
i i
love how so when that when that shadow
campaign article came out from time
magazine
i posted something like you know they
they said they started this campaign
against
not not against anybody they started a
campaign to fortify the election in fall
of 2019
and i'm like so these high-profile
democrats started
colluding conspiring as per time
magazine's own words
in fall during the democratic primaries
and you do not realize that was like
against bernie too
yeah the funny thing is i'll point that
out and then i get a wave of these
lefties on twitter
saying things like uh you know the far
right is only pretending to support
bernie sanders or whatever and i'm like
i'm supporting i'm pointing out that
you're getting ripped off no why would
you do that for bernie or for uh
biden and kamala in the primaries yeah
well at first
until the the the you know buddha judge
and whoever else
all dropped at the exact same time smear
campaigns against tulsi
and bernie and i mean
i didn't see any like biden stickers
anywhere i saw bernie stuff everywhere i
saw tulsi stuff
and they just went full force fortifying
it
you know foreign
check this out so i say number two
republicans are embracing violence now
this one's actually interesting
there's a question this from american
perspe uh perspective survey january
2021
if elected leaders won't protect america
the people must act
even if that means violence 39 percent
of republicans
agree 17 percent of democrats agree
the interesting thing is i bet if you
were to add progressives to
democrats because i doubt it's the same
thing you ask like an anti-foreign black
lives matter person or democrat they're
saying no right screw the democrats
so they're not in this poll probably i'm
just speculating
i bet it would be like 75 you add all
those people and they're
all going to say of course oh yeah of
course it's crazy because thomas
jefferson said the same thing
i don't necessarily agree with it i
don't think we need to take it there but
what was it the blood of patriots
liberty yeah yeah refreshed with the
blood of patriot brutal
letter it's a lot longer than that but
he has this like one line at the bottom
where he says you know what to say from
time to time
the tree of liberty must be what does he
say watered uh-huh
the blood of patriots and tyranny it is
this natural manure
jeez yeah dude was was but
he was a realist he
i'm actually offended i love
thomas jefferson i do too oh dude i am
offended
he didn't know he's amazing i've got a
collection of thomas jefferson coins
like a special little thing he's a
musician no thomas jefferson is not
antifa
was just joking anti-government violence
he was anti-fascist i'm sure that's
technically correct i think i don't know
much about them
yeah but like the problem is anti-fuzz a
brand that has nothing to do with
opposing fashion that's a good point
it's like communists complaining about
fascists but they're just as bad because
they they're only slightly different you
know it's like two murderers and one
guy's like yeah but i use a gun and he
uses a
rifle i'm interested about this this
poll that you that you talked about
where
37 of republicans how many people did
they pull who were they polling
what they didn't say the question was
america must be product
protected even with violence is that
what they said if elected leaders won't
protect america the people must
act even if that means violence what i
don't
see that question should be a hundred
percent of people agreeing
yeah if you're not going to protect
america then yeah of course americans
like that well you see how they're
framing it though yeah if leaders won't
protect america what is that if like
china lands on the shores of
right san diego we just say oh they're
not doing anything i might just go
and run i mean i don't think that means
like
that they want to go do violence you
know
for political defenses fairly like that
question is would you protect america
and
everybody should say yes to that i think
that they worded that a little bit
um it's weird it's a gotcha yeah let me
let me what they write they say the
ultimate
expression of anti-democratic politics
is resorting to violence
more than twice as many republicans as
democrats nearly two and five
republicans
said in a january poll that force could
be justified against their opponents so
i guess it's
against their opponents it would be easy
to dismiss this kind of finding as
meaningless
were it not for the january 6 attack on
capitol hill i'm sorry these people are
so duplicitous
we had a year of riots from antifa we
had 19
dead people plus peripheral you know i
think it's another
12 or 13 in the periphery that were
killed during these riots and stuff like
that
we had in the chas the armed guards
unloading
for 10 minutes hundreds of rounds into
an suv killing two teenagers
and they never talk about it because
they are duplicitous duplicitous
manipulative liars antifa attacked a
federal building two nights ago in
portland
nobody talks about that yeah what
happened um
they attacked what was it the u.s
customs building i believe
they started vandalizing it spray
painting it uh people in
in portland actually were going out in
the streets and yelling at them
it was pretty interesting really yeah
but nobody talked about it
that was an attack on a federal building
that's horrible but it happened at night
so it's not right i forgot about that
yeah
i'm you know i think portland i i
totally support antifun portland
yeah 100 you know why they deserve it
well they voted for it yeah but here's
the problem those people are going to
destroy that city they're going to get
scared because it's going to get violent
it's going to get unsafe
and then they're going to flee to the
red areas that are safe and then they're
going to vote for the same crap that got
them into that mess
so they're fleeing to texas they're
going to destroy texas
they're you know the the problem is that
once they destroy it
they're going to come and destroy our
places too if they had just stayed there
and we had a big wall around it and we
were like do your thing i'd be like okay
cool
yeah wipe each other out i don't care
but
that's not what's gonna happen they're
gonna flee and they're gonna flee to red
areas because they're safe
and then they're gonna vote for the same
policies that got them into the mess in
portland
and you're saying they voted for the
governor that is willing to tolerate
the street violence well all of their
officials they're
local officials city councils yes yeah
geez those people are crazy and then you
see them fleeing to texas and you
you know they're all fleeing to red
areas because those are the safe ones
and it's like
are you guys thinking about why those
are the safe areas they never do
is it guns it might be guns it might be
guns it might be
yeah there's a ton of videos from when
antifa tried going into like some red
areas
and they just got stomped and armed
society is a polite society yeah that's
correct
i think they're saying in l.a they
wouldn't go down on the crunch of
boulevard
oh they know where they can't go there's
people have guns
that's really it so even if it's in a
city that banned guns they won't go
anywhere near that stuff
yeah but the way i see it with portland
is
all of these people voted for it and now
i'm supposed to feel bad for them i hear
what you're saying
we'll have to be prepared for that when
they start you know trying to come in
and there's a funny thing i was i was at
a gun shop and this guy was telling me
he's like oh yeah all the liberals are
starting to move into the red areas we
can tell
because they'll be complaining about
like my neighbor's trash or something or
like
the the neighbor you know put something
on their lawn and we all look at them
like
so my local facebook group there's a
thread with like hundreds of people
involved and they're all like we need to
start telling people
from massachusetts in new york and dc
how bad it is here
yeah we have monsters and our frogs bite
and we play banjo all night
it was really funny and everybody was
just like you know we would normally
would want peop
want people to move here we want to be
inclusive we're nice people
but they're going to ruin our our
community yeah
what if you couldn't vote in an area
that you moved to for like three years
or something
i say this all the time on twitter and
people attack me and say that i'm
anti-democracy but i i honestly believe
that you shouldn't be able to run for
office especially if you haven't lived
somewhere for a while
and i i think that you should have less
say in local politics if you just moved
in
i agree oh yeah absolutely i think that
people who have established roots
should have a little bit more say on
like local politics
think about like mitt romney bouncing
around the country because he's rich he
owns property in a bunch of different
places
and then he's like i'm gonna run for
office as a you know for
for the you know senate in utah yeah
just because i'll sign a piece of paper
saying i live here now it goes even in
local politics you have people who are
who don't even live in the community
running for the school board and stuff
we have people running
school boards in red areas that are from
blue areas and have
completely different politics in the
local community and it's not well
not right the problem with the system is
that the changes
you need to secure the system take
longer than the exploits to destroy them
right
so you'll get someone from a blue area
thinking i'm going to go and teach all
these redneck kids
how to be you know anti-racist and the
parents don't realize these people are
coming in right and then by the time
they're like we got to change this like
congratulations in five years you might
actually change the system
and by then your kids are going to be 17
and they're going to be totally
indoctrinated with this stuff
yep there you go so here's another
interesting one from the vox article
they say
republicans see democrats as something
worse than mere rivals
republicans who consider democrats as
enemies 57
political opposition 43 and democrats
who consider republicans as enemies is
41
and political opposition 59 percent i
don't believe it no i don't believe it
either that flies in the face of the
echelon insights
where they asked it was it was it's a
company they asked democrats what their
you know
how how concerned they are with various
things the most
threatening thing to the democrats was
trump supporters the second biggest
concern i should say biggest concern
white nationalism white supremacy blah
blah blah
for the republicans it was like illegal
immigration and taxation so for them to
come out with this poll
i i question the way they're phrasing
you know these questions like the other
protecting america would you protect
america with violence
i'm surprised every republican didn't
say of course yeah i'm surprised
democrats didn't say yes too
you should protect yourself i'm not you
have to protect your home i'm not
surprised and they're not saying like
protect it from other americans the
questions just would you protect your
home
of course you would protect your home
but it's that question's insane
right it's like they're they're assuming
that the the threat to america that the
government's not stopping is like a vote
a voter fraud case or something and like
that yeah
but if they're talking about actual
invasion and the in a la presidential
ineptitude then the answer is yes 100
percent of the time or your country's
in our constitution like that's amer
an american value look if we remain on
this path
with this being the ideology that if you
say something like that you're
considered far right or
bad well this country's gonna fall apart
that's it it's over yeah
violence is a weird conversation you
know especially no just in general i
mean you do it
of course online of course in public
because you got to be careful about how
you phrase violence and frame violence
and talking about violence but like it
it was the the crux of our country's
formation we had to violently overthrow
our our political rivals our
the the british monarch and over like 20
years it wasn't
people don't realize this that it took
like 20 years slow moving yeah
yeah there were a bunch of things that
happened like the the was it the boston
massacres that was i think the right one
yeah
that that wasn't like these things
happened years apart from each other
so we we view this history as entirely
condensed because it's like the key
talking points but imagine like
when we look back on history in 100
years or 50 years
they're gonna mention everything that
happened in the past four years in rapid
succession and people will think it like
happened one after another when it was
like
the battle for berkeley happened what
was that now two and a half years ago or
something
yeah yeah that was a while ago yeah two
and a half years ago yeah it was like it
was i think it was like march of 20 no
it was almost
wasn't it it's like march or april of
2018
was it 2017. i don't remember 2017. no
no
oh yeah i think it's a long time it was
2017
it might have been yeah yeah because
like after i got back from sweden yeah
wow what was that uh is when this huge
battle happened between antifa
and like right wing groups in in in
berkeley and we saw the based stick man
he's like finally 17 2017. yeah
wow holy moly so this was the uh
the rise of the based stick man they
called him and it was like all these
conservatives were getting just
absolutely clobbered for a year or two
without fighting back
and then one day they do this rally
everybody gets beat up and
i think it was the second time this dude
shows up with
with goggles a mask a helmet a shield
and a giant
stick i think it was a closet dowel you
know like for hanging out yeah
and he cracked it over this antifa as a
woman wasn't it
he like sure he cracked it and it
shattered over someone's head and
they're like
but it's like i watched this stuff go on
for years in
in san jose i watched that guy get
smacked in the back of that with some
kind of bag i said it was a bag of rocks
and he's just a regular guy he was
walking down the street and he was like
yeah an
election god is speaking to us through
the internet
no some site just auto loaded anyway so
i saw this guy he's got a sign and he's
yelling trump trump trump
some dude runs up behind him and smack
it has a bag and whacks them with it
and then it's in there covered in blood
like confused as to what happened
that was i think i think that was in
2015 i'm not sure it might have been
2016.
i'm not sure it's all it's all been ours
together can't believe how long it's
been
yeah and so far so so we see the battle
for berkeley it's like finally
some right right-wing individual started
saying enough and fighting back
and then all of a sudden i remember i
was there and i saw proud boys there
like three proud boys
and i was like what are the proud boys
doing here what is this who are these
guys like why are they here why are they
fighting
like they're getting arrested now what's
going on that was when things started to
really really heat up
that was years ago so it's crazy isn't
it imagine in like 50 years they'll be
like the second american civil war
and then they'll be like in 2017 the
fight broke out in berkeley california
in 2020 donald trump did this and you're
like whoa whoa whoa that was three years
later
yeah isn't that crazy that's the other
thing too that's kind of driving me
crazy
it's like how how long is it going to
keep going on for it's getting boring i
don't know
it seems like it started with the
housing crisis i'm trying to just be
more like
observant from the outside it seems like
it started with the housing crisis when
it really started to get crazy and then
the drone strikes and everything like
like obviously the september 11th
was when the everyone went on high alert
patriot act everyone was thinking
terrorists are all around me oh my gosh
and that kind of heightened the fear and
then but the housing crisis
probably probably angered a lot of
people and then obama bailed out those
those mega corps inequality occupy wall
street
and then at occupy wall street you had
this bipartisan rage at the system
and then all of a sudden the leftists
came in with critical race theory and so
you know woke activism and then it just
made the conservatives leave
and then honestly you also had people
like hannity fanning the flames
like his whole his whole thing was
ragging on the left this was the most
annoying thing to me about occupy wall
street
was that i knew a dude who went on
hannity's show and hannity started just
criticizing and ripping
you know going after him and he just
argued back and they fought and i'm like
why would you do that why wouldn't you
be like sean
you are correct the people who are doing
awful things down there
are bad what do we do we don't want them
here this is a bad thing for us
we want to fight against the big banks
that are ripping people off and the
bailouts and all that system
what what would you advise us on instead
it was adversarial like you're our enemy
and we don't like you because you're fox
news
and that was a big component of it like
there's another guy who got a ton of
attention because he was interviewed by
griff jenkins of fox news
that's his name right griff jenkins i
don't know him i don't know this name am
i getting griff's name wrong
anyway and uh
they didn't use the didn't use the
interview and so someone else recorded
the interview i think it was from
um the village voice i'm not sure and it
went viral because he was like fox news
only does this that and this and you
won't tell what the people are actually
doing
and it was kind of true and then all
that really created out of it was
by like like mutual combat between
tribes
whereas it was originally a populist
uprising with conservatives libertarians
ron paul types
leftists within a week it devolved
completely into leftist critical race
theory
and then it just fell apart thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you